dans l'actualité également j-4 avant le
début du salon de l'agriculture il
s'ouvre ce samedi sur le site Paris Expo
c'est à Porte de Versailles et toute
cette semaine TV 78 mais le curseur sur
nos représentant yvelinois qui seront
présents sur place les Yvelines en le
rappel deuxième territoire agricole en
Île-de-France les producteurs sont bien
au rendez-vous et ce soir on va
découvrir ou peut-être même redécouvrir
pour ceux qui connaissent déjà la ferme
de grignons avec Frédéric Terral je
rappelle que vous êtes le responsable de
la laiterie sur sur place comment aussi
tout à l'heure à nous présenter un peu
le lieu on peut le dire aussi un lieu
qui associe expérimentation production
et aussi un rôle d'information auprès
auprès du public oui on est notamment
ouvert en visite libre gratuit toute
l'année le but c'est de montrer avec un
maximum de transparence ce qu'on fait au
quotidien au grand public puisque les
gens peuvent venir à l'heure qu'il le
souhaitent passer le temps qu'il
souhaite sur la ferme et aller où ils
veulent enfin jusqu'à une certaine
limite sur l'enclos avec les animaux
mais voilà ils peuvent se balader un
petit peu partout au dessus de la salle
de traite voir la fabrication des
produits laitiers l'alimentation des
animaux et ça vous disait toute l'année
gratuitement également bien sûr avec des
animations peut-être proposé aussi à
l'année alors il y a des animations
pendant les vacances scolaires notamment
on a également un temps fort dans
l'année qui est notre journée portes
ouvertes qui a lieu au mois de juin
traditionnellement sur laquelle on
propose beaucoup d'activités diverses et
variées sur sur la journée alors sur
place on le disait des animaux bien sûr
avant de parler de la production
laitière il y a aussi la présence de 600
brebis on parle juste d'élevage là pour
pour uniquement l'élevage voilà le lait
pour les agneaux donc c'est uniquement
de la voilà élevage de reproduction
alors également une grosse présence de
vaches un 220 vaches laitières elles
passent l'année à la ferme elle reste
sur le site
vive il passe toute leur vie
effectivement sur la ferme donc voilà et
grâce à l'Orléans on transforme
quotidiennement enfin fabrique
quotidiennement des produits laitiers
alors quel type de produits laitiers
justement en Fabr des produits laitiers
frais donc le gros notre activité c'est
du yaourt on fait également du fromage
blanc des crèmes dessert du lait
pasteurisé également de la crème fraîche
voilà une gamme assez large mais
uniquement sur de l'ultra frais je sais
que c'est des yaourts qui plaisent en
rédaction je connais des personnes
rédaction qui se fournissent chez vous
et c'est des yaourts en plus reconnus
vos produits ont déjà été distingués oui
on a la chance d'être médaillé quasiment
tous les ans sur le concours général
agricole donc c'est vrai que nous c'est
une vraie reconnaissance pour nous et
pour nos produits et bon voilà ça nous
permet aussi de de voir un petit peu le
retour des consommateurs et voilà leur
avis sur sur nos produits alors il y a
des prix le retour des consommateurs est
bon justement voilà on a un général des
très très bons retours ça fait ce qui
fait d'autant plus plaisir mais voilà on
est quand même sur sur des habitués qui
reviennent régulièrement sur la boutique
et sur les différents les différents
lieux de vente avec qui on travaille
quel type de goût pour les yaourts alors
c'est assez large on va avoir du yaourt
nature bien sûr vanille également des
yaourts aux fruits avec cette parfum
différent une gamme un petit peu plus
originale c'est des yaourts aux fruits
aux huiles essentielles qui sont assez
sympa c'est à goûter je vous le
conseille à l'occasion parce que c'est
vrai que c'est des looks qui changent un
petit peu voilà et puis après sur les
crèmes dessert on revient sur du
classique à chocolat caramel bon voilà
une gamme assez complète et assez large
normalement il y en a pour tous les
goûts yaourt nature yaourt aux fruits
plus tôt pour vous
et du coup ils sont ils sont vendus
directement sur place oui voilà on a une
boutique sur place ou on peut proposer
l'ensemble de la gamme et on travaille
également avec différents alors
revendeurs des crémiers fromager des
boutiques à la ferme un petit peu sur
toutes les Yvelines et même un petit peu
voilà un petit peu partout sur la région
plutôt sur la partie ouest quand même
puisque c'est voilà c'est c'est notre
zone de prédilection je dirais mais
voilà moi on a quand même pas mal de
revendeurs voilà tout est disponible sur
le site de la ferme on a dit qu'avec le
confinement s'il y avait un point
positif à retenir c'est peut-être que
les personnes les Yvelines en
l'occurrence
revenait à la terre si je puis dire
est-ce que vous le constatez vous à la
ferme de Grillon est-ce qu'il y a plus
de de consommateurs en tout cas qui
viennent sur place pour acheter vos
yaourts ou pas forcément en la vraiment
vu lors du premier confinement on est
une très forte demande de nos produits
donc sur la ferme et sur effectivement
toutes les petites boutiques notamment
les boutiques à la ferme avec qui on
travaille bon voilà là ça s'atténue un
petit peu mais on sent quand même qu'il
y a un vrai changement de mentalité qui
s'opère doucement mais qui est là je
sais parce que je sais qu'on pouvait
attendre jusqu'à 1h30 même pour accéder
en boutique non non effectivement il y
avait des fois un petit peu d'attente
parce que bah voilà on était un petit
peu surmergé submergé par la demande
mais bon voilà c'est les gens étaient
quand même contents d'être là et voilà
râlais pas trop de d'attendre il y a
aussi des cultures sur place sur cette
ferme de Grillon 400 hectares
essentiellement qui servent à
l'alimentation des animaux oui c'est ça
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la
quasi-totalité l'alimentation de nos
animaux vient de de nos cultures ce qui
est assez intéressant avec les
différents scandales qui a eu dernière
en termes de traçabilité voilà on sait
pas trop d'où venait d'où venaient les
aliments
très très en alerte sur sur ces sujets
complètement et là encore nous la même
manière qu'on est très transparent sur
les visites on essaye de l'être aussi au
maximum sur l'origine des des produits
que l'on utilise au quotidien pour pour
nos yaourts entre autres quels sont les
autres produits proposés à la ferme de
Grillon en plus il yaourts on fait aussi
du fromage blanc donc là avec une gamme
assez simple à uniquement du du nature
on fait aussi du lait pasteurisé qu'on
va proposer donc soit vous les entiers
soit les demi-écrémé les crèmes dessert
j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure également
de la crème fraîche et on le disait
aussi tout à l'heure il y a une équipe
bien sûr derrière pour faire tourner
cette ferme c'est une trentaine de
personnes sur la totalité de la ferme
une trentaine de personnes et 12
personnes sur la partie fabrication de
produits laitiers dans l'actualité il y
a forcément la sécheresse qui fait qui
fait la une en ce moment avec cette
absence de précipitation on va dire on
va dire remarquable sur sur le dernier
mois c'est une triste réalité qui se
confirme depuis quelques années la
sécheresse ça revient chaque année sur
le devant de la table oui oui donc
clairement on en parle beaucoup parce
qu'il y a ce fameux record et on en
parle beaucoup à l'approche du salon de
l'agriculture c'est vrai que les
thématique rien mais voilà mais c'est
une problématique qui est très présente
depuis plusieurs années maintenant voilà
on voit qu'il y a de moins en moins
d'eau au niveau des cultures voilà les
réserves qui d'habitude nous
permettaient de tenir tout l'été sans
problème ça menuise un petit peu plus
chaque année et voilà c'est vrai qu'en
une situation qui manquait pas encore
dramatique mais qui voilà qui est un
petit peu inquiétante qui inquiétante et
donc vous serez présent je disais au
salon de l'agriculture alors vous me
disiez tout à l'heure la semaine
prochaine oui c'est ça donc sur le S7
qui est les régions sur le stand le
pavillon Île-de-France on sera présent
les mardis 28 février mercredi 1er mars
pour faire déguster nos produits donc
ouais c'est intéressant justement pour
la ferme de Grignon d'être présent c'est
une très belle vitrine voilà on peut
profiter agriculture pour faire les
bouteilles les produits un maximum de
personnes voilà on a la chance d'avoir
quand même pas mal de visiteurs sur le
sur le salon donc c'est vrai que c'est
c'est plutôt intéressant excusez-moi de
pouvoir faire déguster faire découvrir
nos produits à tous ces visiteurs là et
si il y a un attrait aussi des jeunes
pour les professions proposées peut-être
au sein de la ferme ou c'est plus
difficile aujourd'hui d'attirer c'est
clairement plus difficile aujourd'hui
voilà c'est bah c'est des métiers qui
sont très exigeants physiques voilà et
qui peuvent être dur parfois avec des
plages horaires aussi qui peuvent être
un petit peu extensibles des fois
notamment sur des petits structures
comme la nôtre donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus
compliqué d'attirer les jeunes sur ces
métiers là et ça vous est arrivé de
parler de justement de ces métiers aux
jeunes peut-être présent ensemble
l'agriculture ou vous êtes vraiment sur
de la dégustation de produits alors là
cette année on est effectivement sur la
dégustation de produits après au détour
d'une conversation on peut aborder
d'autres sujets et c'est toujours
intéressant voilà de parler de nos
amitié parce qu'il y a pas que la
fabrication des produits et à la
production laitière il y a le soin des
animaux car on a la chance d'avoir plein
de métiers sur l'affaire donc c'est
toujours intéressant d'en parler c'est
quelque chose qui
vous plaît vous le local vous êtes
sensible à ça
oui complètement et depuis tout le temps
ou est-ce que le confinement ça a changé
un peu hautementalité sur la question
et voilà c'est c'est un désavantage
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
voilà en tout cas donc la ferme de
Grignon sera présente sur ce salon de
l'agriculture je le rappelle l'ouverture
c'est samedi 25 février c'est jusqu'au 5
mars à Porte de Versailles à Paris